wow I have eaten some some Rosie very
very important enough for the whole day
yeah so I'm on diet
[Music]
obviously we've got a couple bottles per
second
hello yes we've been to Pratt me I have
my Ginger shot
cookie and one orange that's enough for
me some Rosie very very important I've
got fruit
[Music]
but um
rather squashed egg sandwich
at this point it's just booze good old
cat
and just a bottle of water really
you've got a healthy lunch we've got a
packet of crisps
and a banana
and in all bags we've got some lots of
bottles of water
kitkats
and some oat bars Scotch egg goes
without saying
um olives a little bit Rogue
um and then just some fruit
uh that's basically anything we've got
for 12 hours it probably isn't enough
now in hindsight
um yeah
just
ice